tonight for the first time if you want
Redemption you're going to have to fight
other Smiths to get it the forged and
fire Long Road to Redemption starts here
in this round of competition you're not
just going to mash metal to any shape
instead we've got a custom order one of
these
a jambia
it must be an effective version of this
weapon that is between 8 and 10 inches
in length with a central Ridge you have
three hours in this round your three
hour Starts Now Matt Berry Advanced to
the final round of testing with his
Maasai spear
but his weapon failed at the most
critical moment
so being here for Redemption is kind of
like doubling down on your bet because
if you've lost the first time and you
come back and you lose the second time
well okay yeah you're a loser you
confirmed it the game plan is first get
the stock reduced down to a size that I
can work second stage is to start rough
shaping the dagger gambaya whatever it
is this is going to be really hard
especially in three hours the Grinders
where I'm gonna put in the medial Ridge
so that's just a good adjustment from A
Smith who knows there are multiple Tools
in his shop they can accomplish the same
task I've gotta not grind the ridge but
I have to grind everything else away so
there is a ridge would be a lot easier
to put that Ridge in while the blade is
straight you really need a totally
Steady Hand and eye to be able to match
everything up on both sides it's
probably the hardest grind I've ever
done
wow in less than 10 minutes Matt was
able to put that Center Ridge and it
looks good
Aaron Morrison lost Focus while making a
hatchet I'm the only bladesmith in the
entire Fortune fire history to bust
parameters in round one and round two
it's a little bit disappointing from
somebody who has so much talent I am
here to prove to my family and my
friends and co-workers that I can too
read a tape measure and that it was just
the easy mistake that could happen to
anybody I've never made a champion
before you know now I got to make one
the hardest part about it is creating a
central spine
Do or Die time for a quench I don't have
time to correct this I don't have time
to straighten it I don't have time for a
re-quench this quench has to be the
clinch
there he is
Aaron in the quench
I'll test it and it escapes
I did
but I feel overwhelmed
Chris price was contending with a broken
heart the first time I competed here was
the first thing I'd done after I lost my
wife to breast cancer Chris your blade
did not make the cut understood
when I didn't win it was just one lost
piled on top of another this time I'm
coming from a much better place and I
want to win
I have to make a jambaya I've seen lots
of them I'm familiar with the form
they're not really easy to make but
people make them all the time in third
world countries with minimal tooling so
I've got no excuse here I can't let the
key features medial Ridge be an
afterthought it's got to be my priority
for this knife so I forward it to shape
I have a little W1 left and because I
don't know what's chemistry I'm going to
test it it's the only way to understand
how to do a good heat treat heat it up
normalized break it look at
make sure the knife turns out the way I
want it
some ugly big green
I take my test piece and get it hot
again quench it a second time when I
break it then
it looks better not good better by
double quenching W1 that's going to give
me a nice hard Blade with a nice tight
grain structure
looking good
three two one blade Smith shut down your
machine stop what you're doing this
round of competition is over blade
Smith's congratulations you've made it
into the next stage of this competition
and now that those blades have been
tempered it's time to turn them into
fully functional jambias by attaching
handles to them you can only use natural
materials and you must include four
florets on your jambias good luck
gentlemen your three hour Starts Now to
make the florets the first thing I do is
I make four holes and two pieces of
relatively thin brass and I need to make
this look like a flower
I finally decide I'm just going to
commit and assemble my handle Jay is
going to be brutal on this so I have to
make sure that it's comfortable and
isn't going to hurt a judge's hand
I'm really concerned about the florets
but I can't worry about that at all I
have to clean up the grind before I do
anything else
it's go time I gotta get these stupid
florets attached to my hand
working these small fluorescence is a
pain in the behind the ideal scenario
for attaching florets is having plenty
of pin stock to pin over like matte for
me that's not the case the Florence are
on the floor time is running out
everything is not going right I have my
florets attached now but I have a
sharpened my blade
Chris he's got a huge piece of antler
right there what do you think Jay it's
already very very wide a piece of wood
would be a lot easier
once my slabs are cut and flattened I
need to put some holes in my knife
see the smoke coming off it did it work
nope
if the Steel's too hard there's only one
thing to do
this is trying to kill the temper on
that hole
yes
once I have the floor it's fitted up I
realize I've made a critical mistake and
he's not gonna be able to shape that
panel anymore is he Chris is just
realizing now that his lorettes aren't
going to lay flat instead of a flat
piece of material he's got that radius
antler unlike the other guys who have
flat pieces of wood they could just lay
the florets flat the pins are glued
there there's no starting over with that
so I have to work around the pins and
try and grind down some of this material
really fast
[Applause]
handle it's enormous it's too fat it's
going to be really uncomfortable and
hard to hold I don't know if I'm going
to move on or not
ready Matt
no
nice job man your handle is comfortable
it's a good size the only problem is
it's spinning striking the horn it
turned on me I had to readjust a couple
times but overall very good job thank
you how the nerves doing Aaron not too
good sir all right let's do it
oh
[Music]
Aaron your blade Edge survived the horn
good job on your heat treat you don't
have any deformation on the edge so good
job thank you
so after seeing that how you feel Chris
let's get this over with
[Music]
oh
yeah
you okay I'll be fine
well Chris I cannot hold it comfortably
like this
at all and I put a ton of strain on my
wrist you know like Fireball going off
of my wrist right there but your Edge
held up good work on that thank you
this is the rib rack slice
a sharp edge should cut easily through
this rib rack Matt you're up first you
ready for this
I gotta be
all right Matt this is a very sharp edge
not only did it cut the muscles in
between the ribs it cut the bone
your handle construction is smooth
overall sir here jumbia
we'll cut thank you Aaron your turn you
ready for this yes sir
foreign
about your blade here your Edge on the
outer curve right here is sharp to cut
through bone now your inward curve right
here is sharp enough to cut but not cut
completely all the way into the rib rack
I can index well I grab onto it and your
jambia it will cut thank you Chris
you're up next you ready yes please
[Music]
all right Chris let's talk about your
jambia here your blade is sharp enough
to cut through ribs but then to handle
when you hold it this way it's just too
wide to be comfortable in holding on to
it
but overall sir your chambia it will cut
thank you
blade Smith's the judge's deliberation
is complete
Chris your blade didn't make the cut I'm
going to go ahead and let Jay Nielsen
explain okay so Aaron during the
sharpness test your blade did not cut
completely through on a second strike
the thing about it though is Duck and
walk away unharmed and keep cutting with
that knife Chris your blade is sharp
it's a good blade but the handle is
totally uncomfortable it cannot be held
correctly I actually hurt my wrist
using it I've been in an ice pack since
testing and we can't have a weapon
that's going to hurt the user that's why
we're going to let you go
Chris please surrender your blade the
first thing I'm going to do when I get
home is hug my family tell them I love
them thank him for their support and
take a really long nap